what up y'all this is harry mack known
for all the way live off top fully
improvised freestyle raps and y'all can
check me out on the bootleg kev podcast
let's get it
bullet cav podcast special guest in here
who just tore down the freestyle go
check that out uh on the youtube channel
it's there as well yes sir harry mack is
here yes sir welcome man thanks for
having me man hey yeah man you've been
on your [ __ ] lately bro thank you bro
appreciate that so for people who don't
know um
you're kind of known for your ability to
rap very well but but more importantly
like off of the top of the dome right
which is something that is a lost art
form we have a freestyle series on the
show and i would venture to say 95 of
the bars that have ever been wrapped on
our show was written right um
we still call them freestyles obviously
that term is like evolved
but like in the old school old head term
that me and you live by right you are
the true definition of a freestyle
artist thank you bro i appreciate that
but no like you've done a really good
job of um
you know i feel like people before you
who might have had your talent
um also different eras right but like
you've done a good job of like figuring
out a way to
build like a universe and
monetize your skill so kind of like
you've had a great pandemic yeah yeah
yeah i have yeah it's weird to say you
know because obviously there's been a
lot of pain for a lot of people through
the pandemic and and i think we've all
brushed shoulders with that pain in one
way or another but right from a uh
from a business standpoint for me and
just from a creative standpoint you know
i've had the time and the space to
really build like you say build a
universe around what i'm doing and kind
of build a brand around being an off top
freestyler right now and i think i'm
really fortunate man you mentioned how
you know cats from from the previous era
weren't always able to monetize the off
top freestyle thing
um i feel really fortunate to be alive
in this internet era you know i really
do think it's almost made for that yeah
that's the difference right it's like
now we live in a time where
you know previously it's like if you're
an incredibly talented off-top
freestyler a record label is going to be
like yo that's dope we don't know what
to do with it sorry 100 you know and
it's like okay cool like when you have a
hit song hit us up you know um meanwhile
this talent is like insane and everybody
who sees it live loves it but it just
doesn't fit in with the structure that
sort of exists already now we live in a
time where anybody with a phone can get
on these free platforms and build a
personal brand with whatever they're
into doing and if there's an audience
for it that enjoys it you can monetize
it and so yeah i know you've been doing
this for a while i first saw you on the
cruise show yeah um uh probably four or
five years ago um
and shout out to cruz what what is like
the platform that like really first
started to really like pop off for you
in like a serious way youtube was
definitely the first um
in terms of like in terms of social
platforms you mean yeah yeah yeah
youtube was the first one that was the
big one uh actually youtube and facebook
oddly enough uh because i had a video
back in
february 2017. it was just called uh
venice beach freestyle part one
and it was just me out there on the
venice boardwalk uh scary place to be
nowadays by the way i know yeah it's a
lot different now yeah post pandemic or
whatever mid pandemic whatever the [ __ ]
we're going through right now exactly
wherever we're at in this crazy timeline
what is time anymore anyway but uh
nah man yeah i was out there um it was
funny we had been there all day trying
to freestyle for groups and stuff and
just you know getting rejected right
getting yelled at hey don't do this in
front of my store no filming okay
whatever whatever and we were frustrated
and eventually my my boy who was with me
uh filming it on my phone was like yo
just start rapping and and see what
happens so i start rhyming on the on the
boardwalk and one by one you know this
crowd starts to form and it was kind of
like
it was very serendipitous you know the
crowd that forms
it looks like we hired people to be the
crowd because it's so like diverse and
there's like these like preppy boys on
bikes and like polos and shorts and then
there's like this stoner couple with a
big dude in the bob marley shirt smoking
an l
you know and just one by one it's like
you get sort of this whole picture of
like the diversity of the venice strip
in front of me we ended up with like 40
or 50 people gathered around me and i'm
rapping about everybody's clothes and
everything like that and and um that
video went super viral both on youtube
and on facebook and that was kind of the
beginning of
of uh people knowing about harry mag i
guess how long have you been doing the
omegle uh freestyles yeah i guess
uh
we like a year and a half right so you
started that during the pandemic i
started it during the pandemic yeah let
me ask you something because that's a
sketch place
you know you might [ __ ] around and go in
there and there's a 55 year old truck
driver jerking off like oh yeah
absolutely has that happen
uh that specific well maybe not that
specific yeah he's like i didn't know
his occupation but he was 55 and his
dick was out i've seen some pics
definitely i've seen some dicks but not
as many uh so here's the thing it's
funny actually like before the pandemic
people were making omegle content on
youtube and so people would be in my
comments like yo your [ __ ] would crush
on omegle because really what i make is
reaction based content it's about people
who don't know that i'm going to be dope
and then i do a freestyle and then
hopefully i blow their mind and that's
what's fun about watching it in a large
part so
people would hit me up and be like do it
on omegle but i knew kind of what was up
with omegle and i because i think i just
remember chat roulette back in the day
exactly and it was like a dark place
exactly they always any any site that
randomly pairs strangers on video chat
is a recipe for disaster yes like it's
gonna be corrupted um so i avoided amigo
for a long time and then you know a few
months into the pandemic it's like damn
we can't go out and shoot our regular
content like
let me check this out and see what's up
and actually now it's a lot better than
it used to be because they have these
tags interest tags or whatever so you
could type in hip-hop
whatever you're into whatever you're
into and they also have much and that
creates a lot more filtering so if you
don't use those you see a ton of dicks
if you use those i maybe see you know
like in all my time making the series
honestly in terms of actually seeing a
dick i've probably seen like 20.
it's a solid amount and i have like 60
episodes you know
i mean it's more than i would like to
say not a terrible ratio though
that's why i mean i would like to have
not seen any but i mean 20 is not bad
that's what i'm saying like people
assume because people go on there to try
to find me
and they don't know about the interest
tags and they're like so they're just
like i can't find you on amigo i just
keep seeing dicks yeah and they're like
wow you must have terrible ptsd like you
should be in counseling like the amount
of
of dicks you're exposed to must be
absurd but it's really not it's not as
crazy yeah have you had like a bad
experience on there like where you were
freestyling or something weird happened
i've had some sketch experiences on
there while i'm freestyling yeah like
where where i stopped the freestyling
was like bro you know you need to get
help like people doing like weird drugs
and stuff like on the
on the screen like you're rapping and
then someone comes up with a meth pipe
like yeah essentially
yeah like i don't know what's in it and
it could be a prop you know it could be
they could be trolling but it's still
just like insanely uncomfortable and i
stop and i'm like dog don't don't do
that yeah and also and everyone can see
your face and like don't do you know
people don't understand the internet it
feels like you know where i'm just like
hey man like people forget that that
[ __ ] is there forever yeah it's on a
server somewhere at least forever and
you've got to assume people are screen
capping everything you're doing yeah
this is true so um
what about the tick tock and i know you
were on twitch a lot right so like those
are obviously kind of two platforms that
you know a lot of people i know
uh especially djs took advantage of
twitch big time during the pandemic yeah
um and man i know some people who are
getting crazy checks just djing on
twitch hell yeah um
how did the twitch [ __ ] for you like
because you know we in the hip hop
community we got kenny beatz who's huge
on twitch but like how did you kind of
turn what you do into something that
worked for twitch
yeah so with what i do you know being
being as it's all kind of improvised off
top it's like what i need is some kind
of randomization you know like people in
the chat like yeah exactly we just did a
freestyle you threw me words out loud
that's always dope that's like the
classic way of doing this and uh you
know in this case it's just a live chat
feed people's
putting words in there yeah yeah so
basically any like live streaming
platform facebook live youtube live
twitch um they all work really well for
for what i do um the only the learning
curve was like reading it and and
incorporating it from a written word as
opposed to hearing it out loud it's
different it's like a slightly different
part of the brain or something i don't
know the science of it but it was a a
bit of a challenge in the beginning
because rhyme is all about sound it has
nothing to do with how something's
spelled like devil doesn't rhyme with
evil they look like they rhyme correct
but they don't so
you kind of it's like i have to read it
and then hear it in my head and then i'm
like oh okay now i know where to go why
you're rapping wow you're wrapping yeah
it's a lot of multitasking it's kind of
a
what um
at what point in time were you able to
say to yourself i can fully support my
life off of my skill
wow that's a great question um
i feel like it was like
2018 i feel like 2018.
um i did a mitsubishi commercial
and uh
it was crazy because i i was used to
being like pretty much broke you know um
i'm a jazz drummer i don't know if you
know that but i did not know that my
background yeah so my background is is
playing jazz gigs and um so that was
like your gig like like
besides rapping you were that was like
what paid the bills and teaching drum
lessons yeah i've been a professional
musician supporting myself for a long
time you know i think like 10 years
that's dope yeah but um but the hustle
of a of a jazz
drummer in in the modern world as you
might imagine is a serious it's an
intense hustle serious hustle it's an
intense huh and it's not you know it's
not uh glamorous in any sense yeah i
mean i was playing like bar gigs where
were crammed in a corner and just being
told play quieter play quieter you know
you're disturbing whatever you know
don't do your thing so like stop being
so aggressive and you're out there
trying to pour your soul into this thing
you love and it's like you know we're
doing we're here for the ambiance yeah
yeah exactly and we're getting paid 50
bucks or something and the first couple
gigs we got free drinks second gig
they're like yeah the bar's not gonna do
the free drink thing anymore but same
time you cool so it's a tough grind
shout out to all the jazz musicians by
the way and i have a lot of friends who
are still in that world crushing it
right and um i know what it really means
to be crushing it in that world so so
shout out to anybody doing that but for
me you know i was like barely making my
rant barely barely getting by
um doing jazz gigs and then in in 2018 i
did a uh i got hired to do a commercial
for mitsubishi which was like kind of
based on my videos where i'm dressed up
like a car salesman at the mitsubishi
dealership and then people get in the
car to test drive it and i'm sitting
next to them and then i'd start rhyming
about the car and [ __ ] like that out of
nowhere get reactions and stuff uh and
that was my first like
check kind of you know and it wasn't
anything crazy but like for me at the
time it was like more money than i'd
ever seen yeah it was like just enough
to be like oh i got to keep doing this
is working exactly exactly and i knew
before that that i had to keep leaning
into the freestyle thing just from like
the popularity of the videos and how
much energy there was around it but um
that was the first time i kind of like
got paid and uh and then i took some
time away from youtube and was like
working on a project and stuff like that
like album yeah and that was cool but i
kind of like i lived off the money from
mitsubishi for it it was like a label
advance almost you know luckily i didn't
owe it back
but i lived off it for a while and like
worked on [ __ ] and didn't really think
about like what am i gonna do when this
gets low and sure enough it got low and
again i was at a point where i was like
yo i'm gonna have to like apply to
trader joe's and [ __ ] star i'm gonna
have to like get a [ __ ] job you know
like i looked up one day and was like
i'm gonna have to get a job
and then uh and shout out to my
girlfriend who was like [ __ ] that like
you're dope man like people you have a
fan base you just have to activate some
more of this [ __ ] and like figure out
how to monetize and that's when i
started diving deep into like okay how
can i use youtube like a youtuber you
know what i mean like how can i actually
build this out and and make money off it
and how can i do the same on ig and
twitch and things of that nature and
since then like from a from from a
business standpoint we've been able to
really grow yo stopping the interview
got to tell you about our good folks at
odd socks man listen go to odd socks
official dot com use the promo code 20
off save 20 off some of the craziest
socks you know they got the ninja turtle
joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
i was gonna say do you think that
i think i've what i noticed was a lot of
uh the creatives that i know
the pandemic kind of helped a lot of
people yeah finally shine because it
kind of like reset the world and kind of
like i feel like it kind of
everybody was starting from the same
place yes because you know people aren't
going out to clubs like you know if you
look at the uh best albums of the year
nominees in 2020 it was uh
it was like royce and
j electronica and freddie gibbs and it
was just like all this ill rap [ __ ]
like i feel like like
a certain amount of like
maybe it's time opening up or the way
people are consuming [ __ ] but did you
feel like a uptick in your [ __ ] like
when everything shut down big time i
think it was a few things for everyone
and maybe a few things specifically for
me but one was like
everybody was at home
and
everybody was scared you know what i
mean
or uncomfortable or sad or whatever and
people were just looking for
content to distract them or or to
consume their time you know people were
just sitting on the couch wanting to
watch something you know um to pass the
time and so um people who were providing
content suddenly had an opportunity like
to really step up i think the other
thing is
like previously it's like hollywood is
doing these big budget super produced
things and everybody else is at home
with their little webcam but then all of
a sudden like overnight it was like you
go on netflix and people are on webcams
you watch the news and it's like the
shitty web you know what i mean
with the same webcams and like suddenly
the tech part was taken out of it kind
of where it's like it's not such a huge
difference between a random youtube
content creator and like what you're
seeing on tv right right and so that was
kind of like a leveler i feel like in a
lot of ways
it was a level playing field in some
ways and so then it just came back to
the
quality of what you're making you know
it just came back to like if you're
making something valuable then you have
a you have a chance to really win right
now yeah that's real man yeah pandemic
was good to a lot of people i mean
obviously outside i'm talking about just
career-wise like i feel like people
people definitely like the people who
took advantage of the circumstances you
know
what do they say when uh someone gives
you [ __ ] turn it into lemonade is that a
name but an atmosphere album yes
yeah isn't that an atmosphere it is it
is but it's something it's definitely
not that's a twist whatever i just said
is not the name of the album but there's
some sort of
atmosphere album that's close close
enough to that yes um what are you
working on right now do you have
anything coming like i know you're
putting out weekly videos yeah you're
you're on your [ __ ] but like as far as
like are you going to put out a original
music soon definitely definitely yeah
i'm going hard on the video content as
always um but yeah in terms of original
music i've been having a lot of fun man
exploring kind of
how to use my freestyling to create
records you know and uh because i just
don't i don't like to write like i don't
enjoy sitting with a if i sit with a
blank page and a pen i feel like i don't
know how to rap and i'll just sit there
forever looking at it like i what would
i what would i ever write right you know
and then as soon as it's like okay play
the beat and start the mic then as soon
as i start rapping i remember how to rap
um so for me it's just a thing about
process but we've actually released two
little mini eps like little three song
projects um in the last six months or so
that we're either fully off top or or
like a hybrid where it's like i'll jot
some ideas and then kind of just go in
the booth and go off top and uh the fan
base has been rocking with them man and
so i'm excited to continue exploring
that path we just released one called
soliloquies uh about a month ago that
that uh people are rocking with on my
youtube and stuff like that and and
those are coming out to like dsp spotify
and apple music and all that so i want
to continue kind of exploring that
process of doing what i'm comfortable
with but still being able to release
like official albums and projects what
like inspired you to start freestyling
back in the day like what was that first
like you know yeah it's funny because
there's a couple like really early
childhood like i i saw wayne brady on
who's line when i was in third grade and
i was like
what the i was like i asked my mom i was
like wait what's the trick like they
give him the stuff ahead or he wrote it
in advance is there a plan like i was
the skeptic in my comment section when i
when i first saw him
he's full of [ __ ] yeah because he would
make songs about people you know but he
would sing and stuff it was on whose
line but he would learn their job
favorite color whatever whatever and
create this like brilliant song with the
chorus and stuff off the top that was
the first time my mind got blown from
like lyrical improv and and then from a
hip-hop standpoint uh without a doubt
the the person that lit the fire for me
was supernatural supernatt yeah yeah
shout out to supernatt like he's the go
freestyler i agree um but yeah i i was
exposed to a project he had called the
lost freestyle files um when i was in
like sixth grade i would walk up to
music millennium it was the like record
store by my house and one of the dudes
who worked there was a hip-hop head so
at the end of the hip-hop aisle he would
put like his top five picks of the week
and one week one of those top five picks
was supernatural lost freestyle files
and i didn't know who supernatt was but
i was already into freestyling we would
watch like 106 in park
battles and stuff like that and just try
to try to do our little freestyles you
know we were super whacked but we were
having fun and uh so i saw it in just
off the strength of the title i was like
oh freestyle files i like to freestyle
let's check it out and uh good thing i
did cause that record definitely blew my
[ __ ] mind man like that [ __ ] cause
when i heard supernatt again it was like
the first time i saw wayne brady where i
was like it's not possible like how is
it so smooth
it sounds written
but yet he's incorporating these things
that are proving you know that it's not
written and so like
just that alone was enough of a spark
for me to want to like do a deep dive
and try to figure that out and from
there you expand the universe he had a
battle with juice so i started checking
out juice and then you get on youtube
and you know we were into rhyme series
and atmosphere and then and i learned
about idea who's another idea is crazy
phenomenal freestyler rest in peace so
yeah freestyle fellowship you know bit
by bit we were just nerdy kids trying to
learn about the [ __ ] and uh but yeah
definitely supernatt was the first dude
in a hip-hop context that blew my mind
with the freestyle and then you just
been sharpening your sword
yeah yeah i'm obsessed like i'm i'm it's
scary i'm scared no it is pretty crazy
man
you're [ __ ]
yeah man that's that's no like uh
you you're one of them once oh thank you
bro i appreciate that i appreciate that
it is just pr it really it comes down to
practice and and commitment and putting
the time in you know i always try to
mention that because people see what i
do and they're like
they're baffled by it because they've
never thought about how that would work
right right same way i felt when i heard
supernat and they're just like yo like
how's it feel to be born with this like
incredible blessing and [ __ ] like that i
think i was born with a spark for sure i
think i have a talent for improv and
knack for it but for sure my first
freestyles were wack you would never
hear my first freestyles and be like
he's got it would you ever do what have
they ever hit you do a while and out
uh no not officially not officially they
gotta get you on wilding out you'll body
everybody on there dude that's what i
feel like you're just too nice for
wilding out though
oh because you mean like literally like
you're like you're a sweet guy
it's true man like i don't battle people
see what i do they're like you'd crush
the battle scene yeah yeah but i'm too
nice for that [ __ ] yeah exactly i don't
really like dissing people i don't want
to dis blac chyna and make her cry
right exactly
yeah no that i think that would be the
next thing for you you got to do that
while and i would love to seriously i
would love to yeah i would love to and
and i think you would be uh i mean
obviously you would kill it you'd be the
best guy on there you know man thank you
easily but look i appreciate you coming
through uh seriously you got a couple
eps out now yeah weekly videos your tick
tock is going crazy everything's going
crazy but the big thing right now bro
i'm going on tour tour this year yeah
i'm going on tour energy exchange 2022
is the name you're headlining i'm
headlining it's my headlining tour wow
so you're gonna do crowd work work the
crowd yeah it's a fully improvised set
uh and then we'll do we might i don't
want to leak anything but basically it's
a fully improvised set and uh it's going
to be crazy we got to test it out a few
times uh here in l.a we've done some
shows here um and it goes crazy and it's
going to be wild so check it out we're
starting in february and we're going
across the u.s all the way through
through the top of may wow hey good luck
don't catch that omicron i know
hopefully we're past it everyone's
getting it now so i hope i hope we don't
have a new joint by that time but boom
there it is man harry mack